welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness is in an
illuminata trouble for committing the
multiverse's greatest faux pas wearing
the same stinky accessory multiple
movies in a row how will these judges
ever forgive him i was rooting for you
we were all rooting for you how dare you
learn something from this
when you go to bed at night you later
and you take responsibility for yourself
cause nobody's gonna take responsibility
for you the eye of agamotto mysteriously
returned to the mcu in spider-man no way
home and now with multiverse of madness
despite thanos crushing the artifact
during infinity war and the time stone
that necklace was built to hold being
atomized in endgame now sure thanos did
call that necklace a fake but even after
strange undusted an end game he never
wears that necklace save for a brief vfx
gaff that showed him wearing it in one
frame in the rest of the battle and at
the funeral the necklace is gone and
then in the way home it's back huh but
by looking closely at the new footage
from multiverse of madness and exploring
the eye of agamotto's origin we can
decode this artifact's true nature and
purpose before it was a time stone fanny
pack and why it's so crucial to
protecting the multiverse in the wars
ahead so in the latest multiverse of
madness footage one brief shot shows
strange opening a hatch using his eye of
agamotto he uses the same hand gesture
as he has in past instances to twist the
eye open except instead of the green
glow from the time stone it now emits a
golden glow telling us it had a function
beyond housing the time stone and the
fact that strange uses it to unlock a
door as opposed to using his sling ring
portal suggests that like the eye's
comic counterpart that can see through
all illusions among many abilities that
this artifact may be bypassing other
magic that his sling ring couldn't break
through there was another miscible
moment like this in spider-man no way
home when strange fought spider-man on
the train in the mirror dimension the
eye necklace glows golden and twists
open right as strange tells peter the
merit dimension
where i'm in control now give me my cube
nerd according to wong back in the 2016
doctor strange film the eye of agamotto
was constructed by agamotto himself
mighty agamotto same sorcerer who
created the eye you're so recklessly
borrowed but in the comics the eye of
agamotto has powers far beyond whatever
crystal it contains the director of the
2016 film scott derrickson said that the
i in the comics is too powerful so to
limit its abilities for the film he and
the marvel creative team decided to make
it time-centric and for it to contain
the infinity stone of the time stone but
even more importantly in the comics the
eye of agamotto is actually one of three
that were created by agamotto there was
the ivagimoto of knowledge from the
early doctor strange comics in 1964
which was either the first or the third
eye that was constructed and this one
was given to strange to battle dormammu
perhaps what the first mcu ivagamoto was
based on but there was also the second
ivagamoto of power introduced more
recently in 2019 and an alt-reality
version of that was hidden by strange in
the tomb of fero-rama tut variant of
kang the conqueror for kang to find in
the future and then also around this
time there was a mention of a third
mystery eye of agamotto lost to time so
i believe what we are now seeing in
multiverse of madness and away home is
either the second or the third eye of
agamotto from the comics making the eye
of agamotto restored to its true
function beyond just a mere container of
infinity stone and that now by using it
strange is further desecrating reality
and making the multiverse more
vulnerable to the threat out there who
wields the other long lost eye of
agamotto the villain of doctor strange
three kang so think about it the first i
introduced in the first doctor strange
film the second eye now introduced in
the second film and the third eye aka
the third eye the metaphorical term for
one's mystic essence open your eye
the third eye posing the greatest threat
of all in the third film of this trilogy
one of my favorite details i just
spotted in my latest re-watch of the
multiverse madness trailer was when
strange and american chavez tumbled
together through the realities right as
they pass those dinosaurs you can see
america chavez reaching for strange's
eye of agamotto and only when she
clutches it do they shatter into the 2d
cartoon animated reality and if you look
at the edges of that breakage it is 100
in the shape of a star that means that
america's power to kick star portals
through realities and this eye of
agamotto are connected this eye of
agamotto has some kind of ability to
unlock doors through realities and it
might explain why in this movie compared
to no way home strange now wears a
necklace way higher on his chest closer
to his neck making it harder to grab but
also notice that this necklace does not
appear around the necks of his variants
like defender strange sinister strange
the glorified statue of strange the eye
also appears to be confiscated from him
when he appears before the illuminati
judges during his trial and in the shot
where mordo slashes at his handcuffs and
it's clear why the illuminati doesn't
want strange to possess this eye of
agamotto if this connection between the
necklace and america chavez allows him
to break the realities but assuming the
explanation behind its return is that
agamotto actually built three of these
the real reason for their fear could be
that this second ivagimoto is the last
check they have against the threat who
possesses the third and final eye of
agamotto that threat being kang the
conqueror and or one of his variants
immortus pharaoh rama tut because if you
look back on loki one major easter egg
in the void of pruned people places and
things was an alternate timeline sanctum
sanctorum this means that in some branch
timeline a kang variant conquered one of
the sanctums and its sorcerers and its
artifacts this whole void and he
remained citadel were designed to be
trophy rooms displaying the things kangs
have conquered concept art even included
an iron man helmet on the shelf and then
elsewhere in the void you can see the
great pyramids of egypt and the sphinx
nods to how kang collected the pyramids
as trophies and chronopolis in the
comics and uses the sphinx as his
favorite set of wheels so if among those
trophies was a sanctum that could mean
he who remains and by extension other
kang variants as was the case with
ferrorama tut and ivagimoto of power in
the comics possesses that long lost
third eye so when the second one in this
movie gets destroyed that would leave a
cane variant as the unchecked lord over
the multiverse that doctor strange is
gonna face in the third film i mean hey
maybe even he remains tricked out tempad
was that third eye that thing has some
crazy magic to it so if wanda ends up
wiping out the illuminati in multiverse
of madness brace yourself for a
post-credit scene where strange is going
to return to that courtroom to find the
row of chairs replaced with one throne
from which jonathan majors is gonna quip
time for the whole truth
that's the gambit you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at avos follow new
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching
[Music]
you